خيال علمي يوشك ان يصبح حقيقه وسباق محموم
لربط العقول البشريه بالاجهزه الالكترونيه
لاعبوه الرئيسيون شركات رائده يقودها
مليارديرات على راسهم ايلون ماسك
يحاولون اختراق تعليمات الدماغ للجسد
ونقلها مباشره الى جهاز الكتروني لتمكين
الشخصي من ترجمه افكاره الى كلمات مكتوبه
والتطبيقات الاوليه لهذه التكنولوجيا
ستكون مكرسه للاشخاص ذوي الاعاقات الشديده
كالذين فقطوا القدره على التحدث او
الكتابه استكشف العلماء الاشارات
الكهربائيه للدماغ على مدار القرن الماضي
لكن وتيره ربط نشاط الدماغ باجهزه
الكمبيوتر تسارعت في اوائل العقد الاول من
القرن الحادي والعشرين من خلال قراءه نشاط
الدماغ عبر الاجهزه الخارجيه التي يتم
ارتدائها وتلك المزروعه داخل الجسم صممت
شركه نيورالينك المملوكه لايلون ماسك
شريحه تزرع في سطح الدماغ ويقوم روبوت
متخصص باجراء هذه الجراحه وقد استخدمت 42
شخصا على مستوى العالم رقاقات الدماغ في
التجارب السريريه
الرقاقه تشبه فرشاه شعر صغيره تضم نحو 100
قطب كهربائي شبيه بالسنابل وتكون رقيقه
بما يكفي لتجنب التسبب في الالتهاب وفقا
للشركه المصنعه وهي مصممه لاختراق الدماغ
والوصول الى الخلايا العصبيه الجهاز قد
يسبب حدوث التهاب لكونه يخترق الدماغ
ويمكن ان يؤدي في النهايه الى تلف الانسجه
لكن العلماء يقولون ان مثل هذه الاثار
الجانبيه تعد خطرا مقبولا للاشخاص ذوي
الاعاقات
ولجلب مثل هذا الجهاز الى السوق الامريكي
بنجاح سيتعين على الشركات ان تثبت لاداره
الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه ان التقنياتها
امنه وموثوق بها بدرجه كافيه ليتم زرعها
في ادمغه البشر خاصه ان اداره الغذاء
والدواء رفضت اخيرا طلبا من شركه
نيورالينك لاجراء تجارب على الاشخاص كما
ان هذه الشركات تواجه اسئله اخلاقيه
وامنيه عميقه يثيرها استخدام جهاز يمكن ان
يمنح يوما ما ميزه معرفيه للاشخاص الاصحاء
الذين يحصلون على الرقاقه
[موسيقى]